all right Nikki Nikki wait for
emergently where'd you grow up I grew up
in Culver City from University and tell
me about your family had both your
parents growing I did up until I was
nine that's when my parents split up but
they didn't divorce my dad got a house
in south-central and my mom moved to
Koreatown
you went you went with you I initially
went with my mom and then um I was 15
and my mom got pregnant and I wasn't too
happy about that so I was doing private
Catholic all-girls school and that
helped with the rebellion I guess so
my mom as soon as she had the baby she
kind of like kicked me out and had to go
to my dad's so I guess for two years
from then on I was at my dad's I got
kicked out of private school and things
kind of just went down what kind of
stuff were you doing in teen is a
teenager um I guess it was like the weed
smoking that really like you know tip
everything like over and it was the weed
I guess my dad really didn't like that
either so it was harder for me obviously
to like you know hide like getting high
and like I don't know being at home but
I mean were there any traumatic events
in your childhood abuse um my dad was a
really abusive towards my mom there was
a lot of domestic violence like a lot um
I'm surprised my mom like you know
lasted so long with
but they always say it's like--it's I
did it for you like but nothing directed
at you directly no not really
um I think being like the only child up
until I was 15 like my parents being you
know first-time parents I think they did
pretty well as far as me then not you
know not so much but my dad my parents
did kind of like you know resort to like
spanking and stuff like that I I don't
agree with that kind of stuff you know I
I think there's other ways of you know
teaching your kids how to do the right
thing but I think that's definitely one
of the things that also you know pushed
me over you know I remember once my dad
like once I had moved into my dad's it
was like a weekend so I was like home
all day and he don't really let me go
out too much like at my mom's like she
was caring for my little sister you know
when she was born so at 15 that's when
my mom like my mom used to be really
strict so when my sister was born like
that it all literally just stopped like
like you know I came home one day the
next day and I'd never done that before
and like I was scared you know I was
like oh my gosh there's gonna be
consequences and literally nothing
happened and that's kind of when I was
like okay things are different this is
[ __ ] weird you know but my dad so I
was home one weekend and I was smoking
weed but I didn't smoke weed that day
and I'd been home and my dad was like
also a raging alcoholic so he was
usually always drinking and he came into
my room and he swore that I was high
he's like oh my god you're [ __ ] high
like and I'm like no I'm not like I've
been here all day like you should know
this you know but he was he was pissed
drunk you know so he kind of like beat
the [ __ ] out of me for like no reason
cuz I was not high
and that's like one of like the biggest
memories I have of like getting spanked
but like slash beans because it was bad
and my dad is a big guy he's like six
three I was I was I had just turned
actually sixteen yeah that was shitty
and you left home at what age I'm sorry
you got home at what age as soon as I
was like 18 where'd you go I didn't go
home with my best friend and her pimp
and he he was our age too so he was like
also young and they had an apartment so
like I I lost touch from with my best
friends from like middle school to high
school until I was 18 and then I just
you know I we would keep in touch
through Facebook and I started seeing
like you know she had all these shopping
bags like she had like it was clear like
she had an apartment but there was like
no furniture and just like a ton of bags
to my Gucci and Louis Vuitton and like
Prada and like I couldn't help but like
ask her like what the [ __ ] are you doing
like where's all this money coming from
and she like agreed to she's like let's
meet up you know like legally we'll talk
and at the time I was working for
somebody and I I was I had a work car
like it was my boss's car that I was
driving in like during lunch I could go
and like you know get lunch or whatever
in the car and stuff so it was I had a
lunch break and I met up with them by
Hamilton high school we met up behind
Hamilton mmm-hmm because we were like we
were from that area like we went to
Palms middle school and like all like
like Marvis took over area and yeah like
she pulls up in a [ __ ] Porsche
Cayenne with like her pimp and it's
literally just hurting him and and I'm
already like jaw drop like what the [ __ ]
like this is crazy like this is not just
any kind of money
you know and yeah and she told her she's
like yeah like and I was kind of just
like I didn't know what to say I didn't
know what to do like that wasn't you
know me you know and of course like her
pimp was like you know obsessed with me
like him please like come on like let's
try this out and I I didn't you know I
didn't I was like no like I can't have
to go back to work and she's like to
[ __ ] work I just can't like it's not
even my car you know and um yeah like I
guess like I guess I would say within
like a week or two
I like quit my job like I went to stay
with them I like packed the bag or
something and I just went over there
they had a house they had an apartment
off of off of Palms which was down the
street from our middle school where like
I had first met her and that's kind of
where I grew up too so it was like I
thought I like was loving it you know I
was like back in clover City I was I
think with my best friend from middle
school and yeah that's kind of when I
caught all kind of started so when you
when you started actually working as a
prostitute it was where I'm on the
street I figure out so it was we started
we started I started on on Western same
neighborhood yeah oh no no no no like
more like Hollywood area Oh Hollywood
yeah that's a lot of girls work western
by South Central and then it's also
Western right so we did that and then we
would also do Sepulveda in the valley
and I did do fig but fig was too intense
for me and my pimp saw that that it was
like not just that but like all the
other pimps would kind of like you know
try and like harass me and
because I was just I was like fresh meat
literally he thought I would just be a
better idea to keep me towards like the
valley and western area towards
Hollywood just because maybe it wasn't
as intense but I think it was there was
like no difference to me it was all
[ __ ] intense and and crazy and just
but so the money you would make would go
to him so yeah so when I when I moved in
he was like he was really cool I want to
say like I wasn't I wasn't scared of him
you know it wasn't he wasn't violent not
not that I saw anything I know I do know
that with her he did get violent cuz
that was his bottom you know like that
was his only girl his bottom girl like
his everything his girlfriend everything
you know I do remember seeing her was
like black eyes and like but I never you
know I I don't know I tried to be as
good you know I'm good with him and
follow those rules as much as possible
to like avoid all that [ __ ] and I guess
if I had to I would I would kind of just
go along with what he would say even if
it was kind of like siding with him you
know which started to not work out my
best friend she started to like really
does like that but when I first moved in
he just asked nicely you know like like
just you're just gonna give me all your
credit cards you know all the cash you
have all the money you have and I'm just
gonna hold on to it you know like
whatever happens you know like you'll
eventually get your [ __ ] back you know
you know I didn't really ask too many
questions it was all just kind of I mean
it was self-explanatory I wasn't I
wasn't you know a little girl anymore
you know but it was a little
nerve-racking you know like I'm making
all this money and it's just going there
and
I never you know I never had any cash in
my pocket you know unless we would like
go shopping or something but she would
always get like more money than I would
and even though sometimes I would make
more money than her you know like so but
how much money were you collecting so we
would have like I'm in a certain amount
you know like we'd have to come back
with at least a thousand a night and I
remember at the beginning like I didn't
know that you know because I started off
on Western and Fagen to pull Verdun all
those places like I thought you know I
thought a hundred bucks was enough from
up from one person you know but then I
met I met this you know this one guy on
on Sepulveda and he when he asked me you
know how much I need it or whatever and
I told him like I thought I was like you
know he had a badass car and like he got
a room that was a first time the first
time he I got a room you know we got a
room with one with one of these guys
like it wasn't like a car date or
anything like that and so I was like
okay I can ask for a hundred bucks like
it's got to be way more than that so I
asked him for $300 and he just like
stayed quiet and he was like you're
joking right and I'm like mm-hmm as I'm
like I said too much I can like I'm
sorry like I don't know like what do you
have okay you know and I realized like I
was asking for not enough right like I
was I should have asked for a lot more I
guess and I guess that's kind of when I
started to also realize like yeah I do
just go you kind of trial-and-error
along the way like no no one's really
like [ __ ] teaching you anything you
know and you're just kind of there's no
school for this not at all so
yeah I remember that day I I had made
enough way before my my sister or
whatever and I kind of just like stayed
on the street until it was time because
I didn't think I was allowed to get go
back or like make any calls you know
until like she did for something I don't
know like I didn't really know what was
going on so I waited I stayed out all
night when I didn't have to because I
already had a thousand dollars you know
and um when he realized like you know
finally women we so we met up at a
Denny's me and her like we met up and
then we went to Denny's and then he came
and picked us up there and we had
breakfast and you know and I guess he
realized like I had finished way before
time and he was like what the [ __ ] like
why don't you [ __ ] say something like
you know that was kind of like the only
time I kind of saw him piss but he was
pissed for like a good reason I guess
you're working too hard
and so that was when he decided to send
me to Hawaii yeah and then that's kind
of when I started travelling a little
bit if I work can you make better money
when you travel um yeah I mean so yeah I
mean Hawaii is is it's almost legal I
want to say you know it's a huge strip
in Waikiki where they're all over the
place you know there's girls everywhere
no one's really like hiding from the
gods like here you know like you see a
carny like have to duck behind trash
cans and [ __ ] like and out there it
wasn't really like that you just had to
be careful you know with who you were
you know getting into cars with and
stuff like that
but there was definitely more money
traveling so you're making the money but
you're still you know not still nothing
in my bank again ya know like you know
yeah
did the idea at some point come to you
like you could do this without a pen
yeah
there was times where I wanted to pocket
some money you know stash it you know
I'm like I can stash it right now like I
have a chance to do that right now but I
was scared you know everything was going
so good I didn't want to [ __ ] that up
for myself so I never did yeah and you
this this relationship with the pimp
lasted for how long or is it still going
on so
I eventually got into a car with an
undercover cop
this was also in Hawaii I was making a
[ __ ] ton of money like stupid money
no how much were you making I could make
up to like 2008 and I mean to me that
was a lot because here you know you make
you know your dates were like sixty
eighty dollar dates you know and and and
out there you could do you know 350 for
it like as much as you could you know I
realized like that you the number did
only mattered you know depending on who
I was seeing and who I was meeting and
and you know over time you you start to
realize these things and so you kind of
start putting your price on things you
know as you go and yeah and so we had a
room that we were all sharing but the
day that that happened he and her packed
all their bags and like left the room I
managed to talk my way out of that I
don't know how but when I so I called
her I didn't have any ID on me he this
cop the undercover cop actually ended up
calling my mom because he he could tell
you know I wasn't I was I hadn't been
doing this for very long and of course i
bullshitted along the way a lot like I'm
just here with a friend like you know I
kind of made it seem like I didn't know
what was going on but like you know of
course I did but like I didn't head to
him and so he was like look like you
know I basically he to him it was like I
was forced to do this you know like I
you know I didn't have to and I didn't
want to like that's kind of like how he
played it out to him and so he was like
okay look like I'm gonna call your mom
just call your mom and you know tell her
to get you a ticket back home you need
to get the [ __ ] out of here
and he's like as long as you can just
show me an ID like have somebody bring
an ID like I'm not gonna do anything
just like I need to see who you are and
you know I called I called you know I
called her and
she brought she had to go to the Sochi
had to stop working she had to go to the
hotel room get changed you know she had
to get out of like her [ __ ] like baby
doll that she was in if I can put some
sweats on or something and came and like
brought me a my ID my my passport and
she the whole time she's just like
furious I could tell and she was scared
at the same time you know because she
thought you know something that could
happen her you know she could get
arrested or something because obviously
you know the cops not stupid you know he
knows what's going on but but he did
what he said he would you know and he
got and she brought my ID he let her
leave and he talked to my mom and then
um he let me go so by the time I go back
to the room she was already gone
everybody was gone nobody was in the
room so I had they had left me
instructions on what to do like okay
you're gonna grab your shaker and get
out of that room and you're gonna go to
this other hotel room you're gonna get
another room and you're gonna work there
by yourself without you know you're
without the other girl and that was a
first for me you know like I hadn't
worked by myself you know I didn't have
my own room ever I you know everything
like it was scarier for me because I was
alone I felt I felt alone I felt like
they had completely abandoned me they
didn't you know they weren't still in
Waikiki like but that's when I that's
when I guess like kind of like my
depression started to kind of kick in a
little bit and I felt like betrayed you
know like she kind of like they both
left my side you know and as much as I
you know told them not like you know
like I didn't I didn't say anything you
know I didn't say any names and say
anything about you or him or anything
they just you know they weren't like
having it and that was also when I was
like oh I have room now maybe I could
start stashing some money and like but I
still never did and like I I just didn't
I don't
no I don't know I guess at that point I
don't know if this was his thing like
you know our him sing like I felt that
thought that was when he started kind of
having like favorites you know because
we were never in the same room at the
same time and he would say certain
things to me and I'm sure you would say
certain things to her and I don't think
my relationship changed with him like I
didn't feel different towards him but I
felt I felt something had changed you
know as far as our relationship and then
that was also kind of when he I started
to see you know other sides of him you
know and I guess yeah I guess that was
when I like graduated from like new new
fresh meats like you know really like
being out like you know ten toes down
like legitimately and like just not
having anybody you know behind me or
besides me or you know helping me or
anything you know
I don't know I mean I I wouldn't yeah
wouldn't change anything about it you
know it's I learned a lot you know I met
a lot of people I mean I was in Hawai I
was like my first time out in Hawaii so
that was cool
I mean without that I I did eventually
go in Hawaii with like family and
friends and stuff but you know at 18 I
that wasn't you know that was like whoa
like you know making money and I put
myself I mean I don't have any money in
my bank account
no but I'm like shopping every day and
like so that relationship lasted how
long so that lasted after that I think
they were both really uneasy with me
because they they really thought that I
had said something about them they
thought that I had kind of like throwing
them under the bus to like get out of
this thing you know
and because you got away so easy right
but I didn't I mean I never you know
nice car
yeah just felt sorry for me widget like
he just felt sorry for me it looked like
such a deer in headlights out there you
know and and I thought and you know I
thought you know I thought that would be
a temporary thing like okay like you
know maybe in like a couple days we'll
get another suite again and I'll be able
to go back with them but that never
happened and she also started kind of
getting a little like you know uneasy
about things like she thought that
because when you you know when you're
when you're the only when he had the
only girl to him like you're you don't
have to worry about you know other girls
are like having you know your pimp
having favorites or like you know
spending more money on her and did it
she never had that you know like she was
the only one ever making money issues
she was she was cute little Korean girl
she's Korean she you know I remember she
used to call her like a trap star
because she would make so much money you
know like everybody almost turned you
her like you know
she was like very well-known and and I
guess you know I was making good amounts
of money so she kind of started to feel
uneasy about it and I think she had a
lot to do with like him kind of like
distancing himself for me
not that he like had fired me or told me
to go home or anything because like why
would he do that I'm a temporary
bankroll for him you know like you were
a threat well for her yeah right yeah
but eventually I felt it was like our
relationships had changed so much that I
was like I need to go back to LA like I
can't do this out here anymore by myself
like I feel so alone you know and so I
that's when I you know that's when I
asked him like within like two weeks
after that incident happened which had
been like a week and a half into us
being out there I told him that you know
I wanted to go back home I couldn't do
it unless he was gonna put us back in
the same room and he was like that's not
[ __ ] happening leave the [ __ ] so I
was like well then I want to go home you
know and he didn't argue with me or
anything he you know he was like took me
shopping the next day and like he was
like okay like I guess he was like are
you sure like is this really what you
want to do like after he had gone
shopping like no yeah this is so you
know like I still want to go back and he
just like even I told him even when I
get back and I'm still down to work when
I get back you know but he he I guess
for him it was more of like a like a
commitment thing like you know you're
all in or not you know like I guess he
felt like me being out here and working
Western and fig was like half-assed for
me like if you know if I was gonna be
working for him he wanted me like all in
like making [ __ ] thousands in Hawaii
you know like not [ __ ] 1,500 other
tricks on here like you know in LA so he
was like like it also kind of baffled
him like why the [ __ ] would you want to
be out here and not you know NY or
something making
you know I guess it was like the whole
mental thing you know like the my mental
health it was just like it's when you
get back to LA what did you do
so got back to LA I was with my family
for like a week then they came back and
I went back with them I went back to the
apartment but things were just weird y
know when we when when they got when
they got back from Hawaii it was like a
week after that after I got back as well
yeah they came back and you know they
called me and I went back to the house
I'm I you know I had never moved out of
the house you know I had just came back
to LA you know without them and when
they came back to you know back home
till I and I went back to the house at
this point you know it's been like it's
been a couple months I was like three
months
I guess she started to think that I was
like [ __ ] him which I I like I I
wasn't [ __ ] him because I liked him
or I wanted to like have sex with him
like obviously he was just doing it
while she was gone and I never said
anything about that to her she just the
way he would act you know around us when
we were together in the same room it was
kind of like obvious and I never wanted
to make it obvious because I didn't want
her upset at me like that was my friend
she brought me in and she did this for
me and I felt like I kind of owed her
something and I felt like if I you know
at least kept that to myself I felt like
I was kind of doing her a favor because
they eventually you know they eventually
had a kid and like you know they had a
long relationship outside of that world
you know because when they first met
they were boyfriend and girlfriend
and so yeah things between me and her
we're just not good and that was kind of
you know one of the reasons why I was
like I also felt like I was doing that
for her not so much because I didn't
want to do it anymore
you know because I I had fun you know
like doing all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
around or just being like you know it's
just being crazy like he wasn't he
wasn't he wasn't a violent person with
me you know he wasn't I don't know like
I actually respected him a lot I I liked
him a lot
I you know I was thankful and grateful
like I don't know if that sounds a
little like pathetic but I mean at the
time like he was like he was good to me
you know nothing like you would extract
you know like we were young like heat
like I said he was he was our age you
know he his family like all the men and
his family were pimps and so that was
his thing you know like that's naturally
what he would grow up to be and do and
so he had a lot of like mentors and
stuff and he knew what he was doing like
it was you know though I admired him I
was like wow like he legitimately knows
what he's doing and all the girls yeah
like he had the prettiest girls out
there like you know when he did like
there was another like another asian
girl that came along she met us up in
Hawaii but I never worked with her you
know together like check like this this
girl was the girl who brought me and she
was one of my best friends like I said
we like we went to middle school
together and stuff and so it was like I
know I was with it I've just you know
just knowing her for so long and and
working with her and doing all these
things like you know we would do dates
together and stuff so like me and her
were very very close
you know like and so you know just the
relationship that I was able to have
with with both of them
not necessarily them together but you
know my relationship with her and my
relationship with him it was nice like
you know I didn't there was no anger no
you know not too much animosity maybe
her towards me yes like you know a lot
of resentment a lot of regret you know
because she did realize that I kind of
came in and [ __ ] things up for her but
so I felt like once I left you know I
was doing her a favor you know it was
kind of like I'm just gonna leave them
alone and let them feed them together
you know so where to go from there
from there I I started stripping and I
knew the whole get down you know I was
like oh I know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
you know and then eventually I was like
wow I never needed I needed never needed
a member like whatever or maybe I did
you know I don't know I mean you know
there's this so much to learn from that
but there was there was stripping and
then you know escorting in I guess
everything kind of just comes along you
know it's it's a lifestyle you know it's
not it's not something that you can just
oh what if I you know like you know I
don't I don't think it could have
happened overnight but yeah that was
that was I and then where are you today
so so there's um I don't know if you
know about about the Korean culture they
have they have these things called
dummies it's where in in in Asian
culture it's not just Korea I think it's
like all sorts all parts of Asia they
have you know they have kind of like
brothel type things where they have you
know they have like these rooms like
some of them are like really really
fancy they have like rooms and like they
have the girls I need up and then you
know customers from like all over the
world like they come and they sit in a
room and like it's like kind of like an
auction off you know like they have the
girls with numbers and stuff and whether
it's like a business meeting with like
you know like wealthy business dudes or
whatever like or it's just one person
you know they think they have they have
girls and and they basically choose you
from like a crowd of girls you know like
who they want to be with or whatever so
believe it or not there's like something
similar to that out in LA they have it
everywhere they have an internment it's
go they have it in New York
Vegas super super super underground but
that's what I've been doing for eight
years ago this is a pretty much
exclusively Asian clientele so at the
beginning it was it was mostly Asians
now it's a little more you know it's a
little more diverse but the agency that
I work for they are Korean so but it's
it's it's not just Korean psa's
Armenians Russians you know Chinese Thai
with Thai Filipino you know there's like
white guys and black guys I mean it's
literally all sorts of people and this
is probably much safer than then working
the street definitely did you have some
bad experiences when you were phoning
your wife with you know all these years
it's literally just been one bad
experience and drinking was an issue for
me at the beginning also stripping you
know there's a lot of drinking and
stripping or of course like you know I
had my days where I was like [ __ ] [ __ ]
what my money oh my god and I literally
like so I got to like you know I had to
teach myself I had to learn on my own
like not you know I mean no one's
telling you not to take five more shots
you know so that was hard you know but I
definitely learned my lesson I learned
it good because it could have been
really bad but coming into the domi
world again there's lots of drinking you
know I've been I've been kicked out of
rooms where you know they ask you like
oh are you you know like what do you
want to drink today and then like oh
like I don't I don't really want to
drink today and like okay well I'm gonna
have to dismiss you then you know so you
know if you're not working you're not
getting paid you know obviously it's not
like the agency pays you hourly it's
like if you're not booked you're not
making any money so I can be out at the
venue all day and like
if I don't get booked I'm not making any
money you know so yeah so never say
you're not drinking because you're not
gonna make any money and that's like
that's one of the biggest reasons why
these you know people go there they want
to drink you know it's like the biggest
thing you know that's how everybody kind
of like it socializes through that you
know and it's kind of hard not to drink
when you doing with all this stuff but
just you know I just got to be like
moderate you know pace yourself
and yeah the the the the one bad
experience I can think of was I had been
I went to a venue I'd like some friends
that were here from out of town and I
was actually at one of the venues and I
wasn't actually on the clock like I
wasn't with my agency I had just brought
I had got a table for my friends who are
out of town and I ended up partying with
them but because I was still dressed you
know like in a cocktail dress and all
that I looked like I was working I don't
I don't know what I I think I had just
gone to the bathroom and I was a little
drunk so I was kind of like you know
stumbling a little bit and I was like
two doors from the roof from my room and
these two huge like Russian guys like
kind of like hovered over me and they're
like hey like what are you doing and the
venue wasn't so busy that night it was
like it was actually after hours so if
they have lots of after-hours um you
know shindigs that they do and it was
late you know maybe like four or five in
the morning the venue wasn't too busy
there was a lot of empty rooms mm-hmm
and they were like oh like what are you
doing it was just those two guys and
there's like nobody in the hallways and
you know I'm not really everything's
just kind of happening you know like I'm
not doing anything I'm just going back
to my room like oh like you want to come
hang out with us and like the guy like
he like pulls out like five hundred
bucks and he was just like kind of like
shoves it down my bra and I'm like okay
cool like I'm like I'm just gonna take
this and go like
but next thing I know like one of the
guys like you know he like kind of swung
a door open and the other guy shoves me
in and one of the guys ran in behind me
and the other guys like closed the door
behind him and so I was like stuck in
this room with this guy and hadn't not
been for one of the waiters walking by
within a minute of that happening I
pretty sure I would have been raised
like 100% but I was able to like bang
the [ __ ] you know the wind it was
like the doors have like little glass
like windows so I I bang the door and
the guy like kind of saw me like
struggling in there and he he came in
and he opened the door and he was like
you know like and the guy's tried to say
that like I stole their money but I was
like you know but by then I was like
crying you know like and and I was
obviously like super scared and
obviously that's not what had happened
obviously how was I gonna take this 500
bucks from them you know like and yeah
they got kicked out and I mean they said
sorry like wow you know but yeah the
cool thing about that is is about these
places is there are no there are there
is no security okay there's no security
there's no there's no telling if you're
gonna get paid or not you know that
night or the next night you know you
just kind of have to you know be good at
reading people like us and and just hope
that you know like you entertain them
enough that they're not gonna walk away
without painting because who's to say
that you know you're not gonna be in
this room the these four guys for three
hours and they're not just gonna get up
and walk away and not pay you right and
so when when there's incidents like that
you know that that's why we have that's
why we work for agencies you know and I
say quote unquote because you know it's
just like a you know a group of like
Korean guy
that you know kind of just like they say
you know like we'll be there if you need
any help or whatever but I mean they
just come in and say like come on you
need to pay her you know like and then
the customers always make some stupid
[ __ ] excuse as to why they don't want
to [ __ ] pay you or whatever and then
they'll be like they'll eventually pay
you like half of what they're really
supposed to pay you and you still have
to pay the house you know you still have
to pay you know you know your your your
your dues or whatever but doesn't happen
as often as you would imagine so that's
that's cool her drugs or alcohol a part
of your life yeah when working you know
I don't I don't like to drink
I've always liked been a weed smoker I
guess xanax I've been like making my
anxieties usually like through the roof
a lot I'm an issue I guess with anxiety
so but you know xanax and alcohol don't
mix so I've kind of stopped a lot with a
xanax because I I know that I have to
drink for work like I'd rather drink
than take a xanax bar because xanax
marled blocked me out all night and a
drink won't so and there's a lot a lot
of the girls that do work are like you
know they're like sober you know they
don't they don't take xanax or smoke
weed or excuse me um and so like you
know you see all the girls that are not
taking xanax bars and like you know
popping pills and taking ecstasy and
it's like there's a lot of competition
you know you don't want to be the junkie
girl or whatever and you know like so I
think that's cool you know I can look
around me and be like okay like make
sure I'm not like [ __ ] up you know
like so I mean I I I enjoy it
I've met a lot of cool people lots of
cool people and people are respectful
some people are not sinful or rude but I
think that's just anywhere in any job
you know like I'm just used to making
fast money and I think that's just
the only thing we're gonna be used to
this lifestyle ever get you depressed
sometimes
but there's look there's there's more
like happy times than depressing times
so I just try to not drink too much and
not wake up like what the [ __ ] happened
last night that's definitely gonna
depress you um yeah so I mean I spin
years I you know I what advice would you
give to a young girl that's considering
doing something like this just don't
lose focus of what you're really doing
this for you know which is I would hope
the money you know it's you're here for
the money like don't don't forget that
than the night you have to make sure you
have a certain amount of money here or
that you go home with money in your
pocket like don't get too [ __ ] drunk
don't get too caught up and you know
like partying because that's that's what
it is you know everybody likes to
distract you with like drugs and alcohol
and coke and you know ecstasy and and
next thing you know you know you don't
get paid so I think those were the only
times where I was just like [ __ ] like
what am i doing you know like when I'd
go home and I'd have no [ __ ] money to
show for [ __ ] 8 hours you know so
just just don't get too drunk don't get
too drunk and keep your money in a safe
place are you saving money now um yes
and no not as much as I should probably
you could not as much as like you know
compared to like what I make you know in
a week like I definitely don't like I I
spend a lot you know like I I I have I
have like a shopping addiction like it's
a it's an addiction okay it's it's bad
but
I definitely need to work on that your
job saving I'm sorry your children yes I
do I do I have a five-year-old and are
you raising your job so his dad passed
away from a drug overdose
three years ago that was the that was
the only time that I that I stepped away
from working you know dummy and we were
together for I left you know I left work
for like two years because he didn't he
was a business owner and we planned it
you know we planned to have kids and
stuff um but then yeah he he overdid it
and I literally woke up to his body one
day and I kind of like lost my mind you
know I kind of lost my [ __ ] and I just
you know at that at the time I just
realized that the the best thing for my
kid at the time was to send my rights
over to my mom because I just mentally
it was not capable you know and I I know
that as much as it hurts me I mean it's
it's painful you know because like we
planned it you know we planned on like
it wasn't like oh I just got pregnant
like no like we this was all thought out
and planned out and so yeah it's painful
to know that you know I'm not raising my
son and and his dad might my husband's
dad passed away when he was when he was
young you know he he he grew up without
a dad so when we had our kid you know
that was like his thing like he wanted
to raise them you know be parents like
be there for his son and so when he
passed away like I just wasn't able to
do that you know and that's that's the
painful part about that but I mean I see
my son and
he's he's he's good working is right now
my mom well my mom is amazing for that
you know taking care of him and she took
the responsibility and it hasn't been
easy but she you know she didn't abandon
me or or Maxwell so so grateful for that
you know she I have my mom helping me
with that I mean I hope I hope in the
longer and I can I don't know get get
him back or something work on because
she hasn't adopted like my I just signed
my rights over to her so we'll see what
happens you see I do she lives she lives
in in Koreatown and but once I signed
over my rights there was social workers
got involved in stuff and because um you
know that we had a dispensary and
because of the him passing away from a
drug overdose they really got involved
you know they were making sure that I
wasn't on drugs and I wasn't around him
so it turned into this whole other
ordeal you know with with child services
so I had this I had so much you know
going on with my husband's passing that
dealing with all the social workers was
just not in my deck of cards so I just
decided to kind of just like pull away
from that whole picture and scenario I
just couldn't deal with social workers
i lash out and I just I was like I'm
just gonna end up [ __ ] saying
something stupid I'm gonna [ __ ] this up
for my son and they're gonna take my kid
away from my mom just because you know
they're they're you know they're that
they're really insensitive I I just it
was it was just crazy how you know I had
a social worker trying to tell me how to
I guess raise my kid when this person
had no kids so none of that made any
sense to me and I just didn't want to
make the situation worse and so I just
decided to just gonna send my rights
over and I'm just gonna like you know
try and work on my mental health and
just knowing that my kids okay like you
know that's okay for now how do you
think all these years of doing this for
a living has changed you I think I've
become very I don't want to say cold but
I'm just like like I don't really like
to deal with it's like I don't like to
deal with people who just kind of talk a
lot and you know there's nothing to show
for anything or or you know just I'd
rather you show me then you know tell me
you know and if you're not gonna show me
then [ __ ] off huh you think this has
changed the way you view men
I mean I've never had a certain view on
men you know I don't have a type or
anything I've met a lot of men but I
feel like just like with women there's a
lot of really stupid girls and there's a
lot of dumb blonde girl isn't a lot of
smart blonde girls and I think it's I
don't know when you fight when you when
you do meet somebody interestingly
that's cool you know it's it's nice to
like you know you can get to know them
in this long it's not just like a dead
end you know I just don't really put up
with too much [ __ ]
you know I'm super like everybody says
like I'm just super straightforward and
like you know I just kind of tell it how
it is and I think yeah my lifestyle has
definitely made that you know a thing
for me like just you can't beat around
the bush you know
don't waste my time don't waste your
time and don't waste my time so but
again I don't I don't regret anything
you know it's I think I think I'm I
think I'm I think I'm okay for now
you know I don't think I think I could
have been you know somewhere worse than
where I am right now and I think I did
good you know for myself thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
for listening
very interesting thing thank you
you